[Music]
eric you are being asked
why you are in favor or not in favor of
string theory
string theory is not going to be
disproved
because string theorists discovered a
piece of fundamental structure that we
didn't know was there now the problem
for string theorists is that they over
succeeded in quantum field theory so we
used to think quantum field theory was
only useful for quantum fields that were
physical and then in the 80s we found
out that it was a general framework like
calculus so it's possible that one day
quantum field theory will be used to
optimize supply chains
or something as insane as that because
it's a general structure the issue of
string theory is i'm wildly in favor of
string theorists when they are behaving
really it's an outgrowth of quantum
field theory um in that capacity this is
they more or less are our smartest
people working on problems and they very
much understand the issue of
renormalization the biggest problem is
that the culture and the culture in
eight in 1980 string theory was
horrendous
it since mellowed and in fact what brian
talks about is the string theory sort of
self-invalidated in the early 2000s um
with you know swamps and multiverses and
the like so they are a lot better than
their critics claim
but the problem is is that we're all
uncomfortable saying things that involve
people the people had a bad culture for
a period of time it's in the process of
resolving itself unfortunately that
terrible culture has poisoned the well
and it has far-ranging implications that
we are embarrassed to talk about in
public
can i follow up on that just briefly
right
so so i have a degree of sympathy with
that discussion you know i
was a graduate student in that period in
the 1980s
and there was a sense of how should we
call it unreasonable exuberance
there was a view and a feeling that this
was it this was the final theory and it
was all at hand and
us young scientists at the point got so
riled up and excited but i was all
coming from a good place this is not
some sort of you know dastardly approach
to try to flatten other areas of science
but it is the case that that exuberant
attitude was
too big and i i agree with that now in
terms of poisoning and ripple effects
it's a little hard for me to judge but
on that point there's a certain degree
of of uh sympathy i have with that
discussion but i would like to just
finish this brief remark by saying when
you put the culture to the side and you
actually look at the science we haven't
really spent any time on it but it's
just worth emphasizing that at least
as a mathematical theory the reason why
we've been so drawn to this approach is
it does at least in principle put
gravity and quantum mechanics together
that's a big check
it does at least on paper
put together the forces of nature and
the particles that's a big check in fact
if you run through the inventory of the
most successful ideas
of the last 50 years in physics
almost all of them have a natural home
within string theory and that didn't
have to be the case it could have been
that this approach to programming
quantum mechanics together looked
radically different than anything that
we ever saw and we couldn't even imagine
how older ideas of physics might
naturally be
embedded in this structure so that's
really where the appeal is it's not some
sort of approach where we want to wipe
out the rest of physics it really is the
successful ideas mathematical though
they may be within the theory itself
that has drawn us to it brian
um
wonderful that we are coming together
intellectually but we cannot bury under
the rug the the number of uh i was on
the other side of this it wasn't uh
irrational exuberance uh you know milai
was not irrational exuberance it was
actually an attempt to say we more or
less have this everyone else is a poser
loop quantum gravity is a fraud
only stephen weinberg's asymptotic
gravity
got a little bit of a pass
it was an absolute uh nightmare to deal
with string theorists they were doing
amazing work but a lot of that work was
actually in the geometrization of
quantum field theory
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas